good uh good morning good afternoon
whatever uh
uh welcome uh to the um
our thursday um research conference in
the department of medical informatics
and clinical epidemiology
um as uh as sometimes uh happens i
uh see faces i don't recognize which is
actually good thing meaning that the
information is getting out as you
probably know we have a
speaker that's a little bit different
today than some of the usual speakers
moving away from some of the
detailed technology issues but which of
course everyone
recognizes is such a critical issue for
what we do
which is privacy so our speaker
today is andrea meyer
who's the legislative director of the
aclu of oregon
she's been in that position since 1999
during the legislative session she
monitors
all kinds of issues not just
health i.t but other issues and and
their civil rights implications
everything from
privacy reproductive rights free speech
glbt
issues religious freedom and criminal
justice
she also handles aclu efforts on
initiative petition and ballot measure
campaign work
in 2001 andrew was appointed as privacy
representative on the advisory council
on genetic privacy and research where
she continues to serve
and prior to joining the aclu she
clerked for
u.s magistrate janice stewart and also
practice at a small civil litigation
firm
in portland she's a graduate of the
lewis and clark
law school and did her undergraduate
work in
oberlin at oberlin college and so she's
going to
give us her thoughts on this issue and
she has promised that she'll leave
plenty of time for discussion and i'm
sure there will be
some and so i will let her get started
thank you and uh i understand this has
been advertised as a powerpoint free
talk and it will be so that's it
but i want to and i will watch the clock
and try to leave time
for the opportunity for discussion and
dialogue i want to thank you for the
opportunity to present aclu's
perspective regarding the creation of
electronic health care records
as i think you all know the issue raises
many questions as well as challenges
and i will attempt only to superficially
cover some of the many substantive
issues
overall the question is how do we as a
society use technology
to improve medical practice and care
while at the same time understanding and
addressing the new and different risks
that are created as a result of the use
of technology and let me just briefly
explain for those of you who may not
know what the american civil liberties
union does
we started over 90 years ago when the
u.s attorney at the time general
mitchell palmer began rounding up and
deporting so-called radicals
and thousands of people were arrested
and detained without regard to
constitutional protections
so in the face of those abuses a small
group of people decided to take a stand
and this was born the aclu
the oregon affiliate was started in 1955
we work daily
in the courts the legislature and in
communities to defend
and advance individual rights and civil
liberties so many of you know about the
fourth amendment prohibition against
unreasonable search and seizure
and from that as well as through other
sources arises our concerns about
privacy
while the constitution refers to
limitations against government actions
the aclu looks not only at what the
constitution and laws allow but what
should be the best policies and
practices
in our society regardless of whether
they are done by the government
or the private sector the effective
technology
on our expectation of privacy is an area
that i could spend
days on but i will simply focus on the
issues around privacy technology and
health care
and if i have time i will touch on the
recent state law
implementing a prescription database
monitoring program affectionately
referred by those who are
operating starting to run it as p dump
um
but we will leave that to the end so
what is health it as you all know
generally health information technology
refers to the practice of medicine
through the electronic collecting and
sharing of information
and most discussions center around the
creation and use of personal health
records electronic health records and
databases of these records and
i will focus on electronic health care
records and not the issues around
personal health records
the proponents of health it believe that
everyone will benefit from
such a system for example patients could
have better access to their records of
their treatment and tests
providers could easily learn a patient's
relevant medical history
and researchers could access data about
what treatments work best
but along with that promise of more
efficient and effective medicine
healthit also raises serious concerns
about personal privacy
health records often contain very
sensitive personal
information like treatment for mental
health issues depression or alcoholism
fertility treatments or abortions
sexually transmitted diseases and other
communicable diseases
and genetic disease screening a
violation of medical privacy might
result in the disclosure of this
information to family
neighbors community employers marketers
or identity
and data thieves given the high stakes
in protecting the sense of information
it is essential that medical privacy
form a cornerstone of any
health it initiative it's fair to say
that both doctors and patients
worry that their personally identifiable
medical data will not be adequately
protected
past experience and studies show that if
the confidentiality of electronic
medical records is not guaranteed
a number of unfortunate consequences
might occur
such as an employer after
inappropriately reviewing electronic
medical records deciding not to hire a
candidate for a job
because either the candidate or his or
her family is relatively expensive to
insure
and before there are some amended
privacy rules there were 35 of fortune
500 companies admitted to reviewing job
candidate health records
before making hiring decisions data
brokers buying up pharmaceutical medical
records of millions of patients and
selling them to anyone willing and there
is a 2008 case out of the first circuit
upholding
new hampshire's law prohibiting the sale
of certain pharmacy records to patients
of patients pharmaceutical companies
sending invasive marketing solicitations
to induce patients to switch to
companies prescription medicines
instead of those prescribed by the
doctor i smile i remember getting
something like that
didn't make me happy that they even knew
what prescriptions i was using
persons in small communities or someone
in a prominent position may face
consequences both socially and
professionally
employees and snooping on neighbors
friends and former love interest medical
records
and uninsured individuals committing
medical identity theft by impersonating
insured patients whose records they have
snoop
on in order to obtain treatment health
information technology and health
information exchange
can help improve health care quality and
efficiency
while also empowering consumers to play
a greater role in their health care
however health i.t initiatives pose
heightened risk to privacy recent
breaches of health information
underscore that
real risk at the same time there is
widespread confusion and
misinterpretation about the scopes of
current health privacy laws and some are
pushing for quick fixes to try to
address the public's privacy concerns
but fully resolving these issues
requires a comprehensive
thoughtful and flexible approach i want
to quote a bit
from the center for democracy and
technology in a paper they publish in
may 2008
and a paper was called comprehensive
privacy and security critical for health
information technology rather than
treating privacy
and security as being obstacles
they look at those concerns as a means
of ensuring success
while some persist in positioning
privacy as an obstacle to achieving the
advances
that greater use of health it can bring
it is clear that the opposite is true
enhanced privacy and security built into
health i.t systems will bolster consumer
trust and confidence
and spur more rapid adoption of health
i.t and realization
of its potential benefits they quote
survey data that shows americans are
aware of both the benefits
and risks of health i.t quote a large
majority of the public wants electronic
access to their personal health
information
both for themselves and for their health
care providers because they believe such
access is likely to increase their
quality of care
at the same time people have significant
concerns about the privacy
of their medical records they quote a
national survey that was conducted in
2005 and 2006 and while it's uh
you know only a few years old i think
it's um
hard to imagine that the concerns
expressed then have significantly
changed
in the past few years in 2005
67 of respondents were somewhat or very
concerned
about the privacy of their personal
medical records
in a 2006 survey when americans were
asked about the benefits of
and concerns about online health
information eighty percent said they are
very concerned about identity theft or
fraud
seventy seven percent percent reported
being very concerned about their medical
information being used for marketing
purposes
56 were concerned about employers having
access to their health information
and 53 were concerned about insurers
gaining access to this information
they conclude quote appropriate privacy
protections must be incorporated from
the outset in the design of new health
i.t systems and policies
it is often difficult or impossible oh
did i not say please
it is often difficult or impossible to
establish privacy protections
retroactively and restoring public trust
that has been significantly undermined
is much more difficult than building it
at the start
how can i help i.t be structured to
protect
personal privacy given these serious
concerns about personal privacy it is
essential that policy makers
experts and designers many of you
involved in health it
keep privacy at the center of discussion
and implementation
here are some important questions
related to patient privacy within
any health it systems and i raise a lot
of issues
doesn't mean i have all the answers or
any of the answers but at least i will
raise the issues
how do we explain to patients that
benefits and risks in a way
that can be best understood for
individual choice can patients opt out
of the system
and still receive medical care what
method do we use for whether patients
participate
opt-in opt-out exceptions granularity
is there a way to minimize data sharing
or allow sharing of only part of the
data
a patient may not want a podiatrist or
someone else treating an ingrown toenail
to
see their psychiatric records an
adolescent may not want a parent to see
that they've been treated for a sexually
transmitted infection for example
who decides what specially protected
health information is
state law the medical community patients
isn't it different for everyone can
patients access their own
data at no cost is there a way for
patients to add information or raise
concerns about the facts in a medical
report
i'm currently reading the pain
chronicles by melanie thurnstrom
and i'd highly recommend it uh but what
was interesting is she said when she
received copies of her records the first
doctor she saw
had the very basic facts about what
triggered the aunts ever complain
completely wrong if records can't be
corrected how can they be clarified
from a patient's perspective how will
patients control who has access to their
information
how is the data secured how will
patients know when their data has been
disclosed
under what circumstances do patients
receive notice of data breach
how is medical identity theft handled
are there remedies available to a
patient
if their data has been breached how
anonymous is data
that has been aggregated or
de-identified
what type of auditing system is in place
to ensure proper use
what means are taken for patients to
meaningfully understand their rights
so i'm going to discuss a few of these
in more detail
patient choice and the issue of opting
in opting out and segregating records
based on the sensitivity of the
information
first while this issue is very important
i think the center for democracy and
technology makes an interesting point
quote if health privacy rules fail to
address the range of privacy and
security issues
through concrete policies and i might
add meaningful remedies
which i will discuss below and instead
rely only
or significantly on giving individuals
the right to consent to multiple use and
disclosures other personal health
information
the result is likely to be a system that
is less protective
of privacy and confidentiality among
other reasons a consent based system
places most of the burden of privacy
protections on patients
at a time when they may be least able to
make complicated decisions about the use
of their health data
most don't read the details of a consent
form and those who oft
do often do not understand the terms
many wrongly assume that the existence
of a privacy policy
means that their personal information
will not be shared even when the policy
and the accompanying consent form say
just the opposite
if reliance on consent by an individual
for any particular use of his or her
information
is treated as policy makers as the key
to privacy protections the health care
industry will have fewer incentives
to design systems with stronger privacy
and security protections unquote
nevertheless patient control and
meaningful decision making is still a
critical piece
and it raises important policy questions
should patients be allowed to consent at
the front end
to participate in the electronic
exchange of their records
while this may be considered burdensome
if patients understand and choose to
have their information shared
electronically
one can make the argument that it helps
establish an important level of trust
because while there are benefits there
are also risks including possible breach
or misuse
misuse of private medical information
and then when there is a breach of some
kind
and i think it's often safe to say there
will be it's just a question of when not
if does the fact that a patient was
informed about the risks and had some
understanding not only the benefits
but those risks and the safeguards taken
lessen the potential for long-term
damage of a breach such as patients
refusing to participate
in electronic health care exchange or
limiting the medical information that
they share
with their doctor let's look at it from
the opposite
if a patient isn't given the option to
consent is
instead automatically enrolled or barely
informed about how to opt out
and there is a breach what does that do
for patient trust
patients a community or everyone in the
state who did not understand that there
was electronic sharing of their medical
information
but now have their information released
in some unacceptable manner
may never trust the system again and
that may exacerbate the following
problem already noted by the center for
democracy and technology
which they refer to as privacy
protective behaviors
something many of you may have already
heard of it was new to me but according
to the 2005 national consumer survey i
mentioned above
one in six adults 17 representing 38
million persons
say they withhold information from their
health providers due to worries about
how the medical data might be disclosed
quote persons who report that they are
in fair or poor health
and racial and ethnic minorities report
even higher levels of concern
about the privacy of their personal
medical records and are more likely than
average
to practice privacy protection behaviors
they note that we already have a problem
with patients who attempt to shield
themselves from stigma or discrimination
by paying out of pocket asking doctors
to fudge a diagnosis
switching doctors frequently to avoid
having all their records in one location
lying or even avoiding seeking health
care altogether
it may take work but we suggest it's
important to work to explain to patients
the benefits and risks if not only to
ensure that patients are sharing the
necessary information
you need to make medical health care
decisions
and that raises another issue what level
of control does a patient have over the
who's what's where's and whens
of their medical information in the
debate around this
the term often uses granularity which
has different applications but in
general allows the segregation of health
information
sometimes based on specially protected
health information but not always
it refers to segregating data to want
allow patients to exert some control
over the type and level of information
that can be shared
second to restrict information access
electronically to a set of individuals
or entities
three to establish preferences for time
frame and or duration
for what information can be
electronically exchanged
and four to specify the various purposes
for which information access
electronically can be used again it
comes as no surprise
this is a complicated area but a
person's rationale for desiring this
level of control
may stem from concern or fear of how the
information available through electronic
exchange could be perceived or used
a personal preference for privacy or
their individual values
whatever the reason it's important to
acknowledge and respect those concerns
up front
so appropriate steps can be taken to
advance the goal of health information
exchange while still respecting
fundamental autonomy and values
the challenge however is that in the
context of electronic healthcare records
exchange
there is no easy solution to the
challenges raised by these issues
to add another wrinkle while oregon law
has
defines what specially protected health
information is
which requires specific consent for
sharing this information
those laws only cover mental health
treatment some aspects of hiv aids
genetic information and a minor's
reproductive care
that's a start but for many of us what
we consider especially protective health
information
may not be on that list what about
reproductive health care including
abortion and other reproductive care for
adults
that's not specially protected health
information under oregon law
but you can imagine patients not wanting
it released through various health care
systems by electronic transmission of
their records
and what about anti-depression drugs
used for non-mental health purposes
some of those drugs are used for other
conditions that may not fall under
especially protected health information
patients may not want that information
released to every health care provider
if they worry about whether a breach
would lead to the perception that they
have mental health condition
as much as we want to move away from the
stigmatization in our society related to
mental health issues
we aren't there yet as mentioned above
sensitive information may have
significant personal
employment or political consequences
including the loss of employment
public shaming discrimination and
disruption of personal and familial
relationships
there are important policy reasons to
allow for granular approach
especially information that has been
used to stigmatize patients in the past
such as psychiatric or other mental
health
and counseling the use of birth control
and testing for sexually transmitted
diseases
in other conditions or genetic
predispositions that have no bearing on
a doctor's evaluation
diagnosis or treatment for a wholly
unrelated condition
another area to consider can patients
opt out of the system
and still receive medical care this is
often referred to as a
non-discrimination policy
because it allows someone to opt out of
the system without creating a barrier
to care choosing not to participate can
only be a choice
if a patient can still obtain care
regardless of their decision
whether or not to participate in
electronic health exchange
and what about data security and
meaningful remedies
one thing we really do know for sure as
i mentioned is that breaches happen
and the healthcare community is not
immune
every time i've reviewed the privacy
rights clearinghouse website
which i recommend to all of you they
keep track of all the breaches of any
kind
across the country i find that there's
one
breach of any kind on average day
and i see a significantly high number in
the health care
community there are of course risk to
inappropriate access to paper
health care records and with the use of
technology comes the ability to create
stronger use
authentication and audit trails to limit
and track
access to electronic health information
encryption can help to ensure that
sensitive data is not accessed
when a system has been breached i've
been told by those who work
in the it medical area that most
breaches are not from the outside hacker
but by those who are authorized users
of the system but are engaged in
improper access and use
also the absence of strong privacy and
security safeguards magnifies the unique
risk
to electronic health care records unlike
paper records tens of thousands of
electronic health records can be
accessed or disclosed
through a single breach and the result
of the documented breaches across the
state and here in oregon
not only create a real risk to
individuals but it also has a cumulative
effect to deepen consumer distrust in
the ability of health care providers
to provide adequate privacy and security
protections
patients need to know when and how their
data has been breached
we're getting better about requiring
notices related to breach
but notice of any breach of any kind be
it internal or external
should be mandatory and timely and
meaningful security also means
meaningful remedies
and enforcement mechanisms and yes i
mean the l word liability
but we believe we believe that the
failure to take the appropriate steps to
secure data
should subject the entities to exposure
to damages
here i'm talking about the negligent and
irresponsible entity
that has no incentive to insure strong
data security system
because there's no real punishment for
the failure
they need an incentive so that we avoid
creating situations where data is being
inappropriately accessed
and one way is to have exposure to
appropriate level of liability
for the individual who is harmed
not just the state or the federal
government if they fail to take
reasonable steps
finally how do we handle the issues
related to medical identity theft
medical identity theft refers to the
fraudulent use of someone else's
personal information to obtain
medical services or to make false claims
for medical services
in addition to the complications that
arise from straightening out
other forms of identity theft some of
you may have had to deal with this
such as clearing up bills for expensive
services actually received by someone
else
medical identity theft can lead to
inaccurate information in the victim's
electronic health record with possible
dire results for example an identity
thief could obtain treatment under the
victim's name leading to false
information about blood type drug
allergies
treatment or existing conditions which
could then later lead to unnecessary or
dangerous
treatment for the victim as more
personal health information is
centralized under health
i.t medical identity theft becomes more
likely and the consequence is more
worrisome
the victims of identity theft must have
a mechanism to remove
information from their medical records
that may adversely affect their
treatment
and if medical information is
transmitted to various entities
there has to be a way to correct this
information beyond contacting the
originator
of that information this reinforces the
need
for any health i t system to include
robust data
security measures as well as provisions
for patients to discover and correct
errors now no doubt
this is a complicated area and one thing
i've observed in the last few years as
oregon begins to grapple with this issue
is the continued disconnect between the
issues of electronic health care records
and privacy
it's as if privacy is a separate often
final issue on a long checklist
instead privacy needs to be fully
integrated
into every aspect discussion and
decision point related to the
development of electronic health care
records
i've testified before various bodies in
the state involved in this
indeed prior to the creation of the most
recent state commission
high talk health information technology
oversight council
i was informally asked to serve on the
subcommittee of the previous
group related privacy i was the only
non-member who was asked to participate
in this way and while i appreciated the
opportunity
it was also troubling that there was a
significant lack of privacy perspective
from those most involved obviously those
who are involved at this stage are those
most affected by these systems and in
other words those in the healthcare
community
and i appreciate the efforts made by
those attempting to inform the process
to reach out to consumers as well as to
various communities who historically
are less involved in state decision
making processes
however i continue to be troubled by the
conversation
and how absent the aclu voice there is
little recognition let alone meaningful
discussion by well-intentioned people
about privacy from the patient or
consumer perspective
so i urge all of you to be more mindful
of these issues
and to be sure nationally aclu is not
the only group
raising voice to these important policy
i've already quoted from some sources
but i urge all of you to get more
involved or probably
through your work in class for those of
you who are doing that to review some of
the papers and discussions and tackle
these
important privacy issues from the
patient perspective
now since clearly i have more time
before we get to questions
uh i want to touch on um
the state law that was enacted in 2009
that creates the pharmacy database it's
a pharmacy monitoring database in the
state of oregon
and i'm just curious can i have a raise
of hands of anyone who's familiar with
this law
okay
yes i know at least one person who
should be
this is a law that was passed in the
oregon legislature in 2009 but it hasn't
come
into operation yet but
it what it does is it allows the
government to collect
all prescriptions for schedules two
three
and four now i'm sure as many if not all
of you know that's most of your pain
medications
as well other medicines such as ritalin
and sleep aids
the system is available to providers and
pharmacists as well as the government
the aclu opposes because it turns lawful
oregonians
into suspect drug seekers they
anticipate that millions of
prescriptions in oregon
will be added to this database every
year
and many if not most of us
will be on that database and while we
recognize the benefit to medical
providers
those who have concerns about someone
appearing who's a drug seeker
we believe in this case unlike the
discussion around the electronic health
care records
that the risks to patients and consumers
outweighs the benefits
there are significant risks to
misidentification of patients
the system can only use name date of
birth address
some other systems across the country
use social security number
the original draft of this legislation
early on and it was under the auspices
of the
pharmacy board of pharmacy
basically set forth in the state law
they can collect name
date of birth address and any other
information that the board of pharmacy
decides by rule making
translation social security number so
even legislators who were great
proponents of this
had drew the line there and so they
wrote into the law
that that would could not include social
security numbers
but it raises an issue and we don't have
the solution
that's why we think it's a problem what
is a unique identifier
lots of people have the same name
similar names even the same
date of birth in fact early analysis
and summaries by the department of human
services which now has this
talked about the fact that it's really a
tool because there'll be
misidentifications tool for doctors so
if you look up your patient
you've got some questions because they
seem to be appearing in the system
a lot recently that you have a
conversation with them
it also allows pharmacists to look it up
upon presentation of prescription
pharmacists have very different
relationship with patients and consumers
than doctors do
and most often if infrequently they
can't they don't have the opportunity to
dialogue and discuss they may get
you may call in the prescription it may
get a refill they may run your name and
go i've got questions about andrea meyer
well it looks like she's had coding and
this and that at various
uh you know pharmacies i'm not
comfortable filling it
law doesn't require the pharmacist to
fill it and if i show up there on a
friday having had a root canal and i've
had a root canal
and i've got a prescription the
pharmacist is uncomfortable because the
database is showing something
um i may be stuck where do i go what
recourse do i have
um this is you know for
for years i when i testified on this
bill
and i talked about the breaches that
occur across the country on health care
records oh they say yeah but
you know it hasn't happened to one of
these so what andrea is saying is really
you know that's not happened to the
pharmacy databases
well guess what happened in virginia a
few years ago the pharmacy database
was hacked and as best we know someone
from the outside obtained
all the information it's now a reality
and here's the concern i would have
about the risks and why someone might be
interested
in hacking the system if you are a drug
seeker
what better information to have my name
and my address
and the fact that if i were a pain
patient and had a lot of medication
legally under the guidance of a doctor
in my
medicine cabinet i have to say if i were
a virginia pain patient or anyone having
you know a number of those medications i
would be quite concerned about my home
so we just think the government
collecting this information
on our personal medical and collecting a
state-run database which can be
accessed by doctors and pharmacists
raises significant risks
i was asked to
provide what a legislator called
sideboards not really heard that term
before but i guess
and and raise the concerns and what
protections we could put in that
legislation
and i did my best and yet maybe not
the best i could do one of the things we
put in there was the ability for
a patient to get a free copy
of their report i mean what
how do we audit this to ensure that the
doctor or the pharmacist
actually has a relationship with the
patient how do we ensure
that the staff people
aren't accessing it but there's just
that there actually is the relationship
um part of it is the patient i want to
be able to get a copy of my report and
see if a pharmacist in medford looked at
my name
well i don't have a relationship with
that i want to be able to report it to
the state and say you need to look at
this
maybe it was unintentional after all
they're writing a name check with the
date of birth
i think there's some automatic
violations in looking at medical records
of people who are not your patient
by virtue of that system that are raised
i know many of you have dealt with and
i've talked to providers i mean there's
very strict issues around looking at
records of people who are not patients
and
how is that handled there well
the commission that was formed was all
sort of the stakeholders in the medical
care community
and uh you know i thought this record
was to be for me to provide an audit
that's what the legislature said and i
want to make sure that that record
that i get a hold of when i look at my
record
includes who's looked at it and when and
i was
disturbed to say the least that one of
the commission members of this group
thought that the report is fabulous so
that the patient could know what
medications they're taking
and have it listed all in one place
completely
misunderstanding the purpose and the
need for patient wanting to access those
records
i understand but i haven't heard for
sure that indeed if i request a copy of
my record
that means i will know who has looked at
my
information and when but i keep urging
the department of human services and
then through rulemaking
to add an additional piece
so i find out that someone's looked at
my record impermissibly
now the law allows for litigation allows
for me to bring a private right of
action to sue
that can tell you for for improper use
but i have to prove it's high eye level
that there was an intentional element
here
now i'm going to tell you most people
don't want to do that
here's what i would want to do i want to
call the department of human services
and say
this pharmacist's provider in medford
has been looking at my record
you need to look into that either their
access needs to be removed the system
needs to be fixed
because someone who doesn't have the
authority is looking at my information
what are you going to do about it
and i keep hitting a brick wall in my
discussion about this
and it not being addressed in rule
making and again
it's kind of this continued issue as i
feel as a disconnect to understanding
from a patient perspective what privacy
protections
we would want um as consumers
so those are some of the issues that
we look at and consider when we're
looking at this
and i'm really happy to try to answer
questions as best i can
i qualify i am not a lawyer who has
worked in health care law
you've probably got other experts here
on that but i'm happy from a civil
liberties issue perspective to
try to answer any questions about that
or anything else i haven't raised
so i hope you thank you
and we have lots of time um i'll start
and
and in starting i would like to remind
everyone
especially those who don't um routinely
attend these conferences if you could
press the button on the microphone in
front of you because um
this is um with our speakers consent
being recorded
and will appear on our website and so we
want to be able to capture your
questions
i i want to uh you know i i think i
think you'll find that most of the
views of folks in this room are are are
mostly sympathetic to yours and
i want to um um ask a question about
granularity because
um one of the one of the concerns i have
well actually a few concerns i mean one
is just sort of the practical nature of
how you kind of keep track
of who can and can't look at when
someone needs emergency care or things
like that
but even to go to your example of the
podiatrist
treating the ingrown toenail you know
that's a surgical procedure
that podiatrists may be prescribing
drugs that could potentially interact
with other drugs that the patient is on
and one of our goals one of the things
we think is the value of these systems
is to be able to detect those kinds of
interactions
he there may be some bleeding even minor
surgical procedures
sometimes you can tell from a simple
blood count whether someone
is likely to have aids or something like
that
you know just some of those kinds of
issues it's really difficult i think
sometimes to segregate
um you know what is i don't even know
the best word describe you know
non-essential
even that's not a good way to describe
it but i'm just curious what your
reaction is to that and you know there
may be other better examples than that
one
um you know it may be the dermatologist
i mean i think we can imagine situations
where the information is relevant
and where the information isn't relevant
and you know you already have that
tension right now you already have is a
patient giving me all the right
information do they remember all their
medications
um have i got all their health care
records were they honest
about everything i think we already have
that tension at play
and i don't have the right answer
but i think it's important to
probably establish the levels of trust
necessary
so that patients are more willing than
not to provide
the information and have the exchange of
information
rather than you know how do you
segregate out but then again
how do you deal with the situation of a
woman at a
who had an abortion um
doesn't want anyone to know i'll just
pick that one because we know it's not
specially protect the health information
under oregon law
the way they're approaching it right now
is in terms of formulae in oregon is to
just look at especially protect the
health information
only which is limited so how do we deal
with the person who had
mental health treatment 20 years ago on
medication or 10 years ago and isn't
having the medication anymore
the episode has concluded they are not
comfortable having that record
transmitted to
institution the institution and doctor
to doctor because it does
increase the risks that if it's
transferred to a number of places
unless all those places have high level
security if there's
if there's a breach in any of those
places it magnifies the risk of the
individual patient that their
information will be disclosed at some
point
um so i don't have an answer
i think we've got the problem today i
you know
i will tell you what doctors i've gone
to and we'll get a copy of those records
if i don't tell you
what doctors i've been to i've been
treated out of state and i come in
for whatever reason you may not have all
my health care records now
so it certainly creates an ease of
transmission and
you know you have that luxury of like oh
great i get that all now and you're in
the er room
you've still got responsibilities there
that exist today when you ask for a copy
of someone's records
if i go to a doctor and i have a medical
health issue
and i've also had mental health
treatment so i've got a separate file
with a separate provider
right now i may make that choice you
know dr smith
yep i've been to dr jones and
and dr uh meyer but i may not tell you
about
dr susan right now and i can control
that
you aren't gonna know right so how do we
preserve the choices that i currently
can make
about those sensitive things it's hard
i'm going to go start over there and
i'll make my way around thank you
with hies popping up across the country
like like mushrooms
um are is there a trend towards opt-in
or
opt-out and should there be a trend
should there be a standard
across states um so i'm not sure that
i'm as well versed on what's
what is really happening i think it's a
discussion in a lot of places
and there may be others i think probably
i would speculate that the trend would
be
to opt out rather than to have someone
opting in but i think there are some
states that are
looking or have done that but it raises
a whole other question
i mean now you've got added onto this
how do states
is it the interoperability i mean how do
we vancouver and portland
how do you do that the protections in
oregon law versus the protections in
washington law
it is a complicated
use of technology that we are creating
i my feeling is that it has been less
patient-centric and
less honoring sort of the consumer
concerns as they approach it because
i mean rightfully so it's the people who
are
the most knowledgeable and who are going
to be using the systems
who are creating the systems they're the
experts i
don't deny that and wouldn't want them
not in the room but how do you really
meaningfully get do you have a consumer
representative
on a commission what does that mean i
mean one person is supposed to carry the
burden of
many different perspectives based on
economic status race religion
senses of privacy there's some people
who go i have nothing to hide share at
all i don't care
except when the government gets it wrong
and they might get detained
um then they might be worried about it
there's others who might go
you know i don't want the government to
know
my mother who is 81 when we would go to
the doctor as children and they'd say
you know
social security number she go why do you
need it because that's as you all know
or some of you are probably
not old enough to know that was how
medical providers that was your id
she she understood social security
numbers for the federal government for
social security she grew up in that time
and i learned early on
ask questions why do you need to have
that number no you can't have it
so um it's it's it's a complicated area
but i think
in terms of really bringing in the
consumer perspective it's it's not
happening as well as we would like
sort of answer part of your question add
more
go ahead i think fitting into both of
these questions
is the question about opting out and
then still getting the quality care
which you mentioned
because i think that as you said most of
the experts are deciding
uh how the systems are being built and i
can tell you that that is true from both
both type of consumers there are two
different type of consumers patients and
healthcare providers
and at this time i think both of these
consumers are feeling kind of
left out from the whole process but
the the promise of health id is
improving quality
so if we if we think that health id is
going to improve the quality
then if you are opting out you are not
going to get the quality which
everybody else is going to get so i i
think that probably
everybody needs to understand that too
right and we need to look at well why is
someone opting out
have we not established the necessary
trust and safeguards to assure them that
we recognize the real risks
we've purchased the cadillac not the
pinto
of the kind of i.t that we need the
encryption and everything the
authentication all those things
and that you know we will treat this
even more carefully than we've been able
to treat paper records
um if you do that on the front end
you may not have that many people opting
out but likewise if someone chooses not
to or isn't ready yet
um you know if it's really
truly a meaningful that you have the
option
to opt out then they still need to
provide you health care
and that's what i was talking about
earlier which is you know if you create
the situation where it's like yeah you
can opt out but well i'm just not going
to treat you then
that's the coercive opting in and that's
not meaningful consumer choice
okay lots of hands great i'll try to
keep my answers short so we
i am excellent talk thank you very much
thank you
i am struck that there is this
dynamic tension between
your point of view and medical
professionals as there is between
defense attorneys and prosecutors
because you are seeing the cases of all
the innocent people
who are unjustly affected by some
inappropriate release of their
information on the medical side
i also know that medical people have to
deal with all kinds of people
whose motives are suspect drug seekers
people who in extreme cases seek to
abuse themselves or abuse their children
by subjecting them to unnecessary
medical procedures
people who want to have who want to
fraudulently bill for medical procedures
not done
so from our point of view i mean i think
as a as a person who has been in the
medical system off and on for a while
i can easily see that there's a lot of
guilty people out there who need to be
caught
so how do you reconcile the need to
protect the innocent with the need to
make sure that people don't abuse the
system um well i think first those in
the medical community and all of us need
to know that you're never
going to solve those issues regardless
of what system you use
you will have all of those still
happening
and you may not be able to catch them so
if you're building a system that you
think this is going to deal with medical
identity theft and drug seekers and and
life
i think your premise your premise is
false
now is it a tool to improve some of
those things
possibly but you already have issues of
trust right now with patients not giving
you the information for concerns of
privacy and other things so you already
have those tensions
and you know that's why we look at the
electronic health care records
because there is a benefit to the
patient i can say yeah you know if i end
up in the er room and i have
and they've got access to the system and
i've been in oregon and they can look at
it
i will get better health care when i had
my emergency appendectomy they had an
old
something of me that showed oh yeah this
is you you're
you are having an appendectomy are you
or appendicitis and you need surgery
um so it's useful um
but uh and sorry i lost my train of
thought because i went back to
to to a few years ago um
so but i think oh so i just wouldn't say
so that's a benefit to me
right electronic health care records i
can as an individual you can sell it to
me you can actually sell to me as a
privacy
person committed to issues of privacy
you can sell it to me and i can
understand that and i will have a
difficult decision
and i get why i should should opt in or
something can't sell to me
the pharmacy database because i'm sorry
i use those drugs in schedule two three
and four i have never had a problem
working with my provider to get the
medication i need
um there's no benefit that comes to me
by having the state
databases there's no benefit that comes
to me the risk of having my
information hacked into and released and
there's certainly no benefit to me when
my
there's a misidentification of me
and it's amazing that in the legislature
when i would talk to staff people or
other folks or lobbyists
i couldn't find one who actually when
they just talked to me personally said
that they like that system now medical
providers do and i completely understand
why it's a tool
so that you try to limit the drug
seekers but you know what that is the
risk of a medical practice
and i'm not sure that's going to go away
by a database you may have a fault sense
of security
okay um i saw that there was someone
back there and then i'll come up here
then i'll go around there
was there someone back there okay justin
you're good
i actually have uh two questions okay
uh the first question is back on a
philosophical question is whether
whether or not patients understand the
implications of not
sharing their information do they
understand that it
it may actually negatively impact their
treatment
the other question is on the pharmacy
databases is will the aclu be
challenging that law in court
uh so let's go to the second one uh
will the eclu be challenging it uh
currently i don't see a legal basis for
which to challenge it
it was a state law passed
there's issues around do they need to
seek specific authorization
from hipaa from the federal government
there's a debate around that
uh there is a discussion that they may
set the system up so that doctors would
get an automatic notice if the patient
exceeds a certain amount
i've suggested that's outside the scope
of the law and what it authorizes
so as of you know we will see uh
these databases and i'll add this quick
thing and then move on to your other
question
what i find amazing and i hope you all
consider is these these databases exist
in like 30 40 other states
no one has evaluated the purpose of them
is to reduce drug seekers
oregon's looking at more as a health
care tool some use it as a law
enforcement tool there's now attention
in oregon from law enforcement and the
others who want to do that but no one
has evaluated
whether these are effective whether
these do what they
hope to do across the country we're
spending a lot of money in oregon
to create this database with risk and i
am really
dismayed that before the oregon
legislature
made that decision they didn't say prove
to us this is
addresses the concerns in a meaningful
and appropriate way and they haven't
um do patients understand the
implications of not sharing
well i can't turn the question back to
you isn't that already an issue today
do patients understand the information
not sharing mental health information or
other information that i talked about
with the study showing that they're
already not
um and how do you how do you deal with
that now is it
yeah it's work it's and i know the whole
issues around cost and everything and
time with patients
the ability to establish those
relationships and that trust
it needs to happen today it's going to
need to happen even more
all right did you push your button
oh yeah thank you yeah so actually it's
uh
i guess my question is related to this
last point that you made
now let's think about two extremes where
uh i go to a health care provider i have
a conversation some let tests are done
then everything gets sort of like
self-destructs you know everything is
taken from the record
that's like the most secure thing right
and then the other end uh
everything made immediately is made
publicly available on my facebook page
something like that so okay
so along this curve
so along this curves uh curve are sort
of points with
different trade-offs for essentially
privacy security versus
added sort of benefit in terms of
medical care
and so the fact that now with consumer
choice
you're suddenly given all these knobs
right
and with granularity actually you're
given many more knobs because now you
have to
essentially there are different
trade-offs for different types of
information
and you have to somehow decide for
yourself where to place this knob in
terms of like
in this trade-off curve i this record
made
available to this kind of provider but
not to that kind of provider
usually you know in social settings i
think when people are presented
with this responsibility it's uh
i don't know if anybody studied this but
you know it's actually
i think it's very hard to ensure that
people are making reasonable or
beneficial choices because it's really
hard for them to
understand the impact of their choices
now
uh you say that this actually happens
right now also
but the fact is now we're thinking about
this scaling up scenario where
hopefully when a sort of all the
information converges there will be
added benefits so we're not talking
about
i mean now it's not really comparable i
think because yes now you can hide your
information that you
had i don't know he had some surgery
some years ago in some other country you
may not say that
but um but that's the whole point i mean
the whole point is that
uh making that decision essentially you
know
of talking about debt or not uh you know
will become part of that knob
adjustment process which it is not today
so
um
sometimes you know offering all these
choices
uh is not necessarily providing
benefit i don't know what do you think
about i i think there are a lot of
challenges
and i think as you know as we as i
mentioned earlier having those privacy
policies where they sign they may not
understand that that's actually less
privacy
um i'm i'm responsible
for the state law related to uh genetic
research possibilities with collecting
biological material and the ability to
opt out
if it's even if it's anonymous research
because with genetic information there
is no such thing as truly anonymous
the challenging societal question is who
decides who knows better how do we get
to a place where the medical
world knows a lot and needs a lot they
know a lot in terms of how to best do
their practices
they need a lot of information to best
do their practices
but our society has to also um
have some control in individuals
and i you you raise the interesting and
and and the challenges
and i don't think there's an answer on
either side i think it's
it's a long process and it's a hard one
did you have your hand up yeah i wanted
to follow up on the pharmacy database
issue because
the way it was when you described it you
were
saying the alerts would come at the
point when the prescriptions were being
filled or the pharmacist would be the
one to intervene
when um it has been shown to be very
effective within the
va system when the information is given
at the point of to the actual physician
writing the prescription
and they do need the information right
now i think they can only get it from
the va
system other locations but
it seems to be more of an issue of
having well-defined roles about who
should see it and maybe
not the pharmacist but that not that the
data itself is at fault or we shouldn't
have the databases
well let's let's address a few things
first of all in terms of the alerts
the sending out that's not allowed in
the law and hopefully they won't go
there
it is accessed by a pharmacist or
provider who submitted the right
who signed up and been authenticated and
then they can access it on someone they
are
or about to prescribe or give these
medications to
um and you're
presuming so yes i've always had a huge
objection to the pharmacist
having it if the role is to provide the
opportunity for the doctor if they
believe that their patient is a drug
seeker and this is giving them a red
light to that
to have that discussion if the doctor
prescribes it then why should the
pharmacist and the doctor
hasn't chosen to check uh the system and
why should the pharmacist have a second
check
and may misread it because the doctor
can say i see
you've never lived in that you know you
you can determine if that's really the
right person
but you're also presuming that the data
is accurate and that you're actually
getting
my information when you look me up um
and that's not necessarily true and
fundamentally well it's a great idea and
i understand the need we are asking our
government to collect that information
and to keep it and we just have a
fundamental problem with the government
requiring
my personal medical information be
turned over to the government
for collection and retention for their
access
in a limited situation as well as
possible doctors or possible pharmacists
to us that's where we draw the line i
don't want the government to have my
personal medical information
and i don't want to be forced because i
have a drug to be entered into that
database
but you have no issue with within system
say kaiser
to be able to do that well those exist
and that's and hopefully you've got the
safeguards and security systems and
that's the private sector so i have less
sort of fourth amendment government
involvement i hope there are the
protections and the remedies available
for me if you
reach that system but that's part of the
system i'm in the legacy system i know
it's all there
let me go back over here you had your
hand up
going back to the um the opt out
issue you know this
this technology is really it's going to
take
decades to really fully realize the
benefits
of the ehr and
people you might be able to get away
with people opting out
now without it making a big impact in
the system but sooner or later
they're going to be real costs
associated
with opting out and these costs are
going to be
in higher insurance claims
in case of malpractice issues or
quality of care issues and
reduced ability to discover
patterns health patterns all these
things so who is going to bear the costs
of opting out well i mean i think you
raise
a good point if we move to giving an
option for opting out
one possible remedy to that risk
is that you've created a system that has
vibrant vigorous safeguards and remedies
available to people when it is misused
or abused or
not secured when you create a system
where if i go
and i'm given the option to opt out but
i understand how secure the system is
and and that in fact i have better
protections now than it was a paper
record
and if there is a breach i know about it
and if you're negligently handling it i
have a remedy available
okay i'm opting in i get it
um or if you're going to move to even a
state where someone can't opt out then
you
better have the best protections in
place because
what your result will be is if if i
can't trust that the information
will not be released inappropriately and
i don't have a choice to opt out
i will not tell you what's going on with
me in my health care i will not seek
health care services
i'll be too concerned that it's going to
be shared and i think so
you've got a cost factor but you've got
a lot of different ways but i think one
of the ways to start addressing it is
the vigorous
security systems and remedies available
to build the best system so that people
if they aren't given the option to opt
out or they're not persuaded to opt out
i guess i guess from a practical
perspective i'm i'm
thinking of if patients choose to opt
out and it costs a healthcare
organization
significantly more money to manage that
patient's care
can that cost be passed along
to the patient and i'm sorry i'm just
looking because
i'm checking on what time someone's
coming to
okay i have to deal with another joint
terrorism task force and a reporter at
our office but i've got a few more
minutes so i can stay
opting out has a cost everything has a
cost and i don't have the answers
i don't have all the answers i can raise
the issues and
yes opting out how everything related to
this has a cost
if this is not necessarily i don't know
i haven't studied
has anyone evaluated whether creating
these systems will actually create more
costs
i mean it's intended to improve health
care and to save costs i don't know that
we know as we venture into this thing
that will take a decade or so whether we
know that that will be the result
we hope so but i don't know if it will
be i
i know a hand over here and so go ahead
how much do you think the fear for the
privacy is based on the fact that people
don't think they can
um get get justice served if they do
have abusers on the system
you know trying to go up against some
somebody who's released information
large company an individual is not going
to have a lot of success in suing them
so how much
is the fear of the privacy is based on
people don't think they can get justice
when they've been
have their information abused you know i
have no study i think that's a piece of
it i think people have all kinds of
different fears and i know with
you know my understanding with hipaa is
released right now if there's a
violation i don't have a private right
of action
so you know the federal government can
pursue if an entity is
violating it but i don't get any relief
so providing that as a piece we've
always urged
to give that safety guard safety valve
and protection
that the individual feel like but but
again like i talked about the pharmacy
database
i mean most people aren't going to want
to sue you have to find a lawyer are
there attorney fees or
even available is it nominal damages
um versus i want you to stop doing that
and have a better system in place
so if yes you want a quick follow-up or
okay okay or maybe two because i
pointed to them but i'll be here okay
okay if we're to believe the
public reports that
prescription drug abuse has exceeded
the overdose rate of heroin and illegal
drugs
would this be an invitation to doing
something about it
yeah we should just let
darwin's law take place and eliminate
the species so that refuses
good question and that presumes that all
the drug abuse going on
is by prescriptions improperly get
received rather than someone going and
shopping in their parents
medicine cabinet and sharing the drugs
so i think a lot of the abuse and i
haven't looked at the data but i think
it shows
a high a significant amount of it is is
not based on
fraudulently obtained prescriptions but
misuse abuse and sharing
of lawfully obtained and you will not be
able to remedy that
with the pharmacy database you are
really only remedying
the drug seeker who is able to get three
five six prescriptions
and that doesn't get to i don't think
youth are you know the troubling numbers
related to youth
and the prescription drugs that they are
using as
will not be resolved that really is
their parents medicine cabinets it's
going to parties and sharing it
um a lot of it not all of it so we
we mislead ourselves if we think that
database is going to resolve those
issues
good great well thank you thank you i
really appreciate it
i was just going to say while you were
talking an email came over my phone that
three people were fired from the
university of arizona medical center
today for
uh disclosing records of people who were
operated on over the weekend and the
problem with that it's good they were
fired the problem is we hear about it
and that reduces our level of trust
because it's happened
no no